[Musique]
la réforme scolaire en marche cette
semaine Vincent payon ministre consulte
enseignant parents collectivité locale
association pour préparer sa loi
d'orientation et de programmation
annoncée pour décembre au plus tard nous
donnons ce soir la parole aux parents
d'élèves pierre frodau donc président de
la FCPE des ivelines et également
thaduser bonsoir vous êtes la présidente
de la PEP 78 en guise d'introduction
pour cette séquence une phrase cette
phrase allit signé Vincent on le
ministre de l'Éducation nous devons
inventer un nouveau système pour lutter
contre les inégalités première question
que je vous pose à tous les deux avec
cette phrase avec également les
engagements qui ont été pris autour de
la réforme les discussions sont engagées
est-ce que tout cela va dans le bon sens
pierre frodeau tout d'abord est-ce que
c'est votre sentiment oui oui c'est le
problème du du verre à moitié vide et du
verre à moitié plein ça va dans le bon
sens mais il y a encore pas mal de
choses qui sont
restées sous le Boissau hein il y a
encore pas mal de choses à sur
lesquelles il faut réfléchir il faut
discuter comme par exemple quel est le
point qu sont par exemple on touche pas
du tout au collège alors que on sait que
c'est le point focal des difficultés
parce pour l'instant la réforme porte
sur le primaire porte essentiellement
sur le primaire ce qui ce ce qui est une
bonne chose mais on touche pas du tout
au collège on revient pas sur la réforme
du lycée qui est catastrophique donc
voilà il y a un certain nombre de points
positifs mais il reste beaucoup de
travail quel est votre point de vue
alors du côté de l'autre Fédération des
parents d'élèves la PEP et bien nous
aussi on trouve effectivement que c'est
une bonne chose annoncer qu'on va lutter
contre les inégalités est un vœu contre
le quel je ne vois pas des parents
s'élever en revanche on attend des des
actions concrètes des nouvelles idées
pour le moment on parle par exemple
d'une allocation de moyens aux
établissements qui serait variable selon
la sociologie des établissements ce
n'est pas nouveau c'est ce qui était
pratiqué par le passé parce que Valérie
Marti qui la la présidente donc de la p
Valérie Marti a déclaré votre présidente
que le Président de la République
formuler quelques propositions gadget
par exemple c'est assez dur finalement
oui vous êtes plutôt critique sur les
les discussions qui ont eu lieu on va
rentrer un petit peu dans le détail tout
à l'heure mais sur les rythmes scolaires
par exemple sur Oui c'est un petit peu
frustrant si vous voulez quand notamment
quand on parle des rythmes scolaires
lorsqu'on en parle depuis tellement
d'années et et qu'on a une un
gouvernement qui annonce enfin qu'il va
refonder l'école donc évidemment on en
attend beaucoup et lorsqu'on voit que on
ne touche plus aux vacances d'été on ne
touche plus au zonage des parce qu'il
était envisagé pendant un temps sur le
zonage pendant l'été de zoner peut-être
les vacances d'été c'est-à-dire mettre
des bah des zones pour les vacances et
puis de raccourcir ses vacances d'été
surtout Ctait ça le il y a eu des
concertations il y a eu un rapport de
soumis il y a eu beaucoup de réflexions
beaucoup d'attentes la semaine la la
semaine des petits Français
effectivement déséquilibré mais on
revient juste sur une journée une
demi-journée d'école soit c'est bien
parce que du coup si on rallonge pas les
programmes ça veut dire qu'ils auront un
peu plus de temps pour aborder les
apprentissages on on on ne rentre pas
dans le détail le ministre annonce que
il a retravaillé sur les temps scolaires
et éducatifs moi ça me laisse un peu
sceptique comment un ministre de
l'éducation nationale va agir sur le
temps éducatif qui est finalement à la
charge des collectivités territ locales
est-ce que on va pas aggraver là pour le
coup les inégalités lorsque des écoles
sont situées dans des communes où on
peut proposer des activités culturelles
à tous les enfants lorsqu'ils seront
libérés voilà ce genre de chose
s'accompagne effectiv pour la p avec
enfin d'une certaine frustration
d'autant plus que nous lors de notre nos
deux congrès une des résolutions qui
avait été adopté au congrès de la PEP
c'était que l'école soit la priorité du
gouvernement donc
nous que c'est une priorité si je peux
placer de mots je dirais que tout le
monde sait que la p c'est l'UMP par an
hein donc c'est en tous les cas comme ça
que comme ça que c'est considéré donc ce
qu'on peut dire pour l'instant c'est que
ce qui est fait pour l'instant c'est
revenir ir sur l'essentiel sur la
destruction du système scolaire qui a
été organisé siamment ces dernières
années donc on sait par exemple que la
suppression de la de la demi-journée
supplémentaire he de la de la 9e
demi-journée qui s'est faite en 1900 en
2000 en 2008 hein par Monsieur monsieur
Chatel ou son prédécesseur on sait plus
très bien lequel a fait le plus de
bêtises euh on est quand même on revient
dessus donc c'est quand même énorme
comme comme modification et ça c'est
positif uneé ça c'est positif et c'est
pas c'est pas la FCPE qui le dit c'est
la plupart ou la grande majorité ou
voire la totalité des scientifiques
spécialisé hein l'Académie de médecine a
dit que c'était une aberration et ça
c'est ça a quand même été fait alors
déjà revenir là-dessus c'est c'est déjà
énorme je suis d'accord qu'il y a un
certain nombre de un certain nombre de
de de problèmes qui se posent bon alors
on supprime on supprime les on supprime
les app on supprime un certain nombre de
un certain nombre de de de montages
comme ça un petit peu artificiel en
disant ben on va donner de l'argent en
fonction du milieu socio-économique dans
lequel se situent les écoles moi je
trouve que c'est pas si mal je trouve
que c'est pas si mal sent plutôt
bienveillant avec la réforme qui
s'engage sur les annonces qui ont été
faites vous avez pas le même sentiment
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes plus
critique du côté de la PEP que du côé
pardon vous m'avez posé une question sur
la réforme sur mon are sentiment de
parents donc je vous réponds monsieur
frudeau va beaucoup plus loin et nous
colle une étiquette donc je ne comprends
pas d'où cette étiquette peut sortir si
ce n'est que nous sommes que nous sommes
en France et qu'il on a besoin les gens
ont besoin automatiquement d'affecter
une couleur politique à une opinion je
ne me permettrai pas d'aller sur le
registre politique mais je crois que là
pour le coup c'est une affirmation qui
est gratuite la PEP est la seule
fédération de parents qui inscrit dans
ses statuts la neutralité politique et
qui s'interdit en sens sain toute
discussion politique évidemment nous
avons des parents qui ont des opinions
politiques certains les affichent
d'autres pas mais nous observons à
chaque fois qu'il y a une réformme qu'il
y ait un changement de gouvernement en
tout cas nous essayons de regarder la
réforme et son contenu indépendamment du
ministre qui la pose donc je ne me
permettrai pas de dire que la bien très
critique avec levec
l'anciver auourhu de revenir mais nous
pourrons échanger avec enfin avec Pierre
nous échangerons volontiers sur voilà
tout à fait donc je vous invite alleer
peut-être regarder les déclarations et
les communiqués de je connais très bien
je sais très bien où trava respons de
on a des opinions qui peuvent être
différentes toujours est-il que moi ce
soir je suis venue parler au nom de la
PEP des Yvelines donc je suis la
président donc à ce titre je suis
responsable des propos que je tiens en
tant que en tant que responsable de la
PEP Eveline il est vrai je voudrais pas
répondre à Monsieur frodau sur le même
registre en
disantut si cette bienveillance est le
reflet
d'une d'une proximité avec la gauche que
vous revendiquez et que vous assumez il
n'est pas obligatoire que la fédération
qui n'est pas de gauche et qui ne se
revendique pas de gauche soit de droite
et on le sent bien ce sera forcément
compliqué pour le gouvernement de faire
une réforme si au sein même des parents
d'élèves il n'y a pas d'unanimité
puisqu'on le sent déjà il y a déjà des
des discussions des clivages vous n'êtes
pas tout à fait déjà d'accord alors on
va juste revenir quand même sur le
détail les propositions quelquesunes des
propositions qui sont faites par exemple
Vincent payon qui déclare cette semaine
aucun élève ne sera dehors en dehors des
salles de cours avant 16h30 c'est une
bonne chose ça vous rassure aussi oui
c'est une bonne chose ouiou avec les
devoirs fait fait à l'école nous c'est
ce qu'on demande depuis depuis longtemps
on pense que ça c'est c'est c'est
fortement euh ça per va permettre
fortement de réduire les inégalités tout
m' dit ruser pour la PEP les devoir fait
à l'école d'accord oui nous sommes
d'accord et je renvoie pierre frudau à
l'interview de Madame Marti euh qui
reconnait exactement les mêmes propos
euh il me semble plutôt que la FCPE
était contre vos déclarations étaient
plutôt opposé à l'existence même des
devoirs à l'école donc nous nous avons
toujours dit que c'était pas forcément
une bonne idée mais qu'il fallait
revenir vir à ce qui avait été fait là
vous voyez une très bonne idée par par
Monsieur Jospin qui avait introduitent
sur débat entre la FCPE et la PEP je je
vous demandis visiblement voilà quel
était votre point de vue votre regard
sur je pense qu'il fallait revenir
effectivement sur la proposition qui a
été faite pour la première fois par
Monsieur Jospin qui avait introduit dans
le programme des écoles élémentaires le
temps de travail parce que les enfants
doivent travailler à l'école c'est
l'école qui transmet les savoirs c'est
l'école qui doit apprendre aux enfants à
travailler et effectivement laisser les
devoirs qu'il soient obligatoires lourds
ou moins lourds à la charge des familles
ou implicitement même si on les
supprimer des familles vont retravailler
ceux qui ont les moyens vont
retravailler avec leurs enfants ou payer
quelqu'un pour travailler avec eux donc
nous applaudissons effectivement le fait
que les devoirs soient faits à la maison
ça c'est quelque chose avec laquelle qui
est accepté et tout à fait entériné par
la p donc tout va bien pour au contre
les devoirs à l'école cette fois-ci on n
pas posé la question aux deux
fédérations on a posé la question à
quelques ino vos
répones je pense qu'il faut un minimum
de devoirs à la maison mais que ça reste
des devoirs de révision de leçons des
choses qui ont été vu en classe voilà et
puis pas trop bah je trouve que
maintenant les les parents ils ont pas
trop le temps de s'occuper de ça donc
c'est mieux que ça se fasse à l'école
quoi ouais c'est pas mal je trouve que
c'est déjà chargé un programme scolaire
est déjà chargé donc du coup ça permet
de profiter un peu des enfants le soir
et qui s un petit peu quoi faut quand
même essayer de de dialoguer avec eux de
faire des devoirs avec eux pour savoir
où est leur niveau exact et si il ont
besoin d'aide plutôt contre parce que
c'est quand même important que les
parents ils suivent quand même le le
suivi scolaire c'est important moi j'ai
une petite fille de de 6 ans qui vient
de rentrer au CP c'est important qu'elle
fasse un peu de lecture un peu le soir
c'est c'est bien pour elle pour les
parents aussi qui qu'on voit un peu ce
qu'ils font à l'école moi je suis pour
l'arrêt des devoirs à domicile pour les
enfants parce que le soir quand on
rentre cont après une journée de travail
on n'est pas forcément serein pour faire
faire correctement les devoirs et dans
de bonnes conditions aux enfants ça
n'empêche absolument pas les parents qui
le souhaitent de faire faire de vérifier
que le le le travail de la journée étaé
assimilé par leurs enfants et de faire
travailler les matière qu'il souhaite on
parle de cette réforme de cette refonte
de l'éducation avec la FCPE avec les
représentants de la FCPE et de la PEP
dans le département des Yvelines on
parlait des devoirs justement faut-il
les faire ou non avant de avant la
sortie des classes en ce qui concerne la
formation des maîtres parce que là aussi
c'est un point important quelles
seraient les propositions quelles sont
les propositions que vous allez faire au
cours de de cette semaine de
consultation du ministre Vincent pon
mais nous on proposait de revenir sur la
réforme qui qui considérait à qui
consistait à supprimer complètement ou
quasiment complètement la formation des
la formation des enseignants donc on est
on est assez content qui que cette
formation soit à nouveau pr prise en
compte car on pense que c'est vraiment
un métier qui un métier qui s'apprend le
métier de d'enseignant de professur il
faut retourner au système des ufm il
faut retourner un système qui qui
ressemble à ça en tous les cas voilà et
c'est apparemment ce qui ce qui est
décidé et de votre point de vue alors
que les enseignants soient formés avant
d'être mis face à des enfants ça me
semble une une priorité les modalités de
la formation je préfère laisser les
spécialistes en débattre parce que les
par vous en attendez quoi vous seriez
plus rassuré que vos enfantsuré
évidemment mais là encore une fois je je
des fois il faut un petit peu corriger
les les informations qui circulent ce
qui a changé effectivement c'est qu'on a
suprimer la formation ça c'est une
catastrophe on a supprimé une année pour
des enseignants qui leur permettaient
d'acquérir un petit peu de savoir non
disciplinaire parce que beaucoup
d'enseignants sont quand même devant les
élèves étaient quand même devant les
élèves sans avoir eu une formation à la
pédagogie ou à la gestion de classe ce
qu'il faudrait ce que nous nous
attendons en tant que parents c'est que
les difficultés auxquelles les
enseignants doivent faire face
devrai enfin il devrait être formé à ces
difficultés là qui sont au-delà du
savoir disciplinaire qui sont
différentes aussi de la pédagogie
exactement il faut les préparer à la
réalité du terrain ce qui n'est pas fait
suffisamment et la réforme a fait que
vous aviez des enseignants qui
arrivaient directement face aux élèves
ce qui était le cas avant aussi les
enseignant stagiaire arrivent devant les
élèves sans être formés sauf que avant
ils avaient 9h d'enseignement et 9h pour
se former et la suppression des des ufm
a conduit à ce que on mette en tout cas
pour le second degré pour les écoles le
système est différ et des retours
d'enseignants laisse penser que c'était
pas si mauvais que ça c'est des retours
d'enseignant que Don dont je vous parle
qui étaaient des formateurs qui
accompagnent les jeunes parce qu'il y
avait un temps d'observation c'était
complètement différent pour le premier
degré et pour le second degré vous aviez
un jeune qui n'avait jamais enseigné qui
avait à faire exactement la même charge
de travail face donc la même charge de
travail le même temps devant les élèves
et une charge de travail forcément plus
importante qu'un collègue qui avait des
années d'expérience et qu donc lui oui
plus d'ésances donc effectivement c'est
important une dernière question très
rapidement pour vous deux puisqu'on
arrive sur la fin de cette discussion
autour de la réforme de de l'éducation
même s'il y aurait beaucoup pas dire
est-ce qu'une seule loi suffirait est-ce
que la loi seule va suffire il y a eu
beaucoup de tentatives de réformer
est-ce qu'il faut aussi travailler sur
les mentalités est-ce que la loi suffira
oui pour nous une frustration reste qui
est qu'il faut absolument retravailler
sur le statut des enseignant et la
définition même de ce qui est attendu de
l'école en général nous avons encore un
gouvernement qui a changé encore une
annonce où je ne sais pas enfin si vous
voulez quand il y a des conflits souvent
c'est parce qu'il y a des malentendus
sur les attentes on entend dire le
ministre que l'école va être l'outil de
redressement qu'elle va faire supprimer
les inégalités social est-ce que on a
vérifié que les enseignants sont
d'accord elle ne suffa elle ne suffira
pas et de votre côté alors du côté de
aussi que la la loi suffira pas qu'il va
falloir modifier les les mentalités et
mais je je je crois quand même que il
faut plus plus ça va plus on plus on
pense plus on sait nous les parents que
le système éducatif doit s'adapter au
monde qui vient et il faut il faut
parler de numérique il faut parler
vraiment de l'adaptation aux nouvelles
technologies fa que la lo reste ouverte
en tout cas faut qu'elle évol derère je
pense que c'est ce qu'a dit le ministre
c'est une première étape c'est c'est un
temps long c'est des réformes qui sont
énormes à mettre en place il y a 12
millions de de d'enfants scolarisés en
France hein donc c'est c'est c'est très
très important donc là c clin suffira
pas c'est un premier pas on a déjà
arrêté la destruction du système
scolaire c'est déjà énorme merci à tous
les deux représentants de la FCPE et de
la PEP dans le département des ivelines
d'être venu discuter de cette réforme de
l'éducation je vous rappelle que le
projet de loi sera présenté par le
gouvernement par le ministre au cours du
mois de décembre